the opening has this great action set
piece in new york city with a huge
monster and i'm curious what is it
actually like filming a sequence like
that is it weeks is it like five days
like can you sort of talk about filming
that specific sequence
well with that you know it's it's hard
because you know you're shooting stuff
kind of out of order
so i could be you know we were shooting
some of that at the very beginning and
then also like towards the very end of
filming as well so it's hard to kind of
keep it i don't know all together but um
one great thing about sam is that he has
all of the stuff that we shoot and he
puts it together so that we can actually
see what we've shot and what we need and
that's great
it helps a lot
for sure yeah it was all it was all shot
in parts probably a number of days
wasn't it number of days number of
months yeah number days months
we've
completely lost track of time obviously
um but it's a
fantastic sequence
aloft in the air i don't know
sequence that's
fantastic thank you i really liked
watching that i watched it like over and
over again thanks that's the sorceress
supreme for you yeah
i got some new powers
i really enjoyed the banter at in the
beginning uh
but anyway um for fans of marvel movies
you've obviously done a number of them
this is your first time for each of you
what do you think actually like fans
would be surprised to learn about what
it's really like making the movie on set
it was so
you know with the conditions that we
were filming in and all the restrictions
it was tough you know and you know full
credit to the crew you know at times it
was like the madness of the
multi-schedule and um you know
i think we we work really really hard uh
on the kind of um
you know hard circumstances that we um
but yeah we're here it's great yeah it
was coming out soon it's crazy was there
anything that really surprised you
um i mean
uh probably like especially with this
movie there's so many
things going on keeping it all
you know on like basically making notes
of what's
going on in each universe that kind of
stuff because it's it's hard to keep
track
eventually the fantastic four and the
x-men will be joining the mcu is there a
character or characters that you cannot
wait to interact with
hmm i like i really liked
yeah interacting with wong okay i did
i think america and wong are great
great screen time there
um
fantastic four the x-men
yeah that's cool yeah let's hang out
with those guys right exactly uh yeah i
can see you guys you're just playing
the curves um we're driving golf carts
right uh i i am curious though so people
know your character from the comic books
and this is the first time it's being
brought to life on screen how do the
powers compare how does a character
compare to what's been in the comics
well what's so great about you know
america and the mcu is that she is way
younger than uh her age in the comics so
we kind of get this new introduction to
her um where she's kind of you know less
experienced um and so it's really
interesting you know
you know from the comics you're so
uh confident and
knows her powers so it's just making
that but
younger wong is a fan favorite character
when when did you realize that fans had
really responded to your character and
you know really loved him
uh i keep being
told this i'm just accepting it uh
yeah i'm look i'm thrilled that it's
getting that sort of response uh
you know i've i've said time and time
again you know from being someone who's
collected all the comics and just feels
like the competition winner really that
goes
and
goes and just appears in various
different movies um
and i get to play alongside many
different people in in the marvel
universes
what a lucky guy thank you
my last thing for you uh and just george
real fast uh i'm a huge sam raimi fan is
there a day or two that you can share uh
like you know memorable moment of
working with him on set i know that one
day he did bring avocados because he is
a gardener yeah i saw a gardener samurai
and he brought like three different
types of avocados he knows how to grow
them he knows what they need he knows
everything you have to know about
avocado trees
i did not know that there you go
and i ate them they were really good he
grows amazing avocados i will ask him
about this
[Laughter]
is there anything
uh just um when i first got the gig and
uh i had my conference call with uh sam
i didn't had a chance to
i didn't have a chance to read the
script as yet and i just had this living
legend just
perform and narrate the the the story to
me and then
surprisingly tell me of course you're
going to be the sorcerer's supreme
i just like
shrilling like it was christmas day
again
on that note can't wait to see the
finished film thank you so much for your
time
you